let me ask you about
objects or one particular object from
outside our solar system
we don't get to study many of these
right they don't
we don't get stuff that just flies in
out of nowhere from outside the solar
system and flies through
apparently there's been two recently
in the past few years one of them is
amor more
what are your thoughts about ammo and
more so fun to say
could it could it be space junk from a
distant alien civilization or is this
just a weird shaped comet
i like the way that's freezed um so
umua is is a fascinating object just the
fact that we have started discovering
things
that are coming in from outside our
solar system is amazing
uh and can can start to study them and
now that we have seen
some we can
design now kind of thinking in advance
the next time we see one we will be much
more ready for it we will know which
telescopes we want to point at it we
will have explored whether we could even
launch a fast turnaround mission to
actually like get to it before it leaves
the solar system
um in terms of yeah it's
for an object in our solar system it's
really unusual
in two particular ways um
one is the dimensions that we don't see
natural things in our solar system that
are
kind of long and skinny we see the
things we see in our solar system don't
deviate from spherical by
that much and then that it showed these
strange properties
of accelerating as it was leaving the
solar system which was not understood at
first
so in terms of the
alien space junk you know as a scientist
i cannot rule out that possibility i
have no
evidence to the contrary um
however so you're saying there's a
chance
i cannot i cannot as a scientist
honestly say that i can rule out
that it's alien space junk however i i
see
the kind of alien explanation
as following this uh the sagan's
extraordinary claims
require extraordinary evidence if you
are going to actually claim that
something is
aliens you need to carefully evaluate
one needs to carefully evaluate the
other options and see
whether it could just be something that
we know
exists that makes sense in the case of a
muammua
there are explanations that fit well
within our our understanding of how
things work so there are a couple
there are two hypotheses for what it
could be made of they're both
both basically just ice shards in one
case it's a nitrogen ice shard that came
off of something like pluto in another
solar system
uh that pluto got hit with something and
broke up into pieces and one of those
pieces came through our solar system
in the other scenario it's a bit of a
failed solar system so our solar system
formed out of a
collapsing molecular cloud sometimes
those molecular clouds are not massive
enough
and they sort of collapse into bits but
they don't actually form a solar system
but you end up with these kind of chunks
of hydrogen ice apparently
and so one of those chunks of hydrogen
ice could have got ejected and passed
through our solar system so
both cases explain these properties in
about
the same way so those ices will
sublimate once they've passed the sun
and so as they're moving away from the
sun you have the hydrogen or nitrogen
ice sublimating
off the sunward part of it and so that
is responsible for the acceleration
the shape also because you have all this
ice sublimating off the surface
uh if you take something the the analogy
that
um works pretty well here is for a bar
of soap
your bar of soap starts out sort of
close to spherical at least from a
physicist's perspective and as you use
it over time you eventually end up with
this long
thin shard because it's been just by
sort of weathering as we would call it
um
[Music]
and so in the same way if you just
sublimate material off of one of these
ice shards it ends up
long and thin and it ends up
accelerating out of the solar system
and so given that these properties can
be reasonably well explained that way
um you know we should be
extremely skeptical about attributing
things to
yeah aliens see the reason i like to
think that it's aliens
is because it puts a lot of priority on
us not being lazy
and we need to catch this thing next
time it comes around
i like the idea that there's objects not
like
it's almost saddens me they they come
out of the darkness
really fast they just fly by and go and
leave
it just seems like a wasted opportunity
not to study them
it's like uh it's the easiest ways
to do space travel outside of the solar
system
it's having the things come to us right
i like that way of putting it
and like it would be nice to just land
on it like
and first of all really importantly
detect it early
yes and then land on it like
with a really nice like spacecraft
and study the hell out of it and
you know i
if there's a chance it's aliens alien
life
it just feels like such a cheap
way inexpensive way to get information
about
alien life or something interesting
that's out there
and i'm not sure if a nice shard from
another planetary system
will be interesting but it very well
could be it could be totally new sets of
materials it could be to tell us about
composition of of of planets we don't
quite understand
and it's just nice one especially in the
case of a momoi this was pretty close to
earth
it would have been nice to uh to uh you
know let's say
don't go there they come to us i don't
know that's what makes me
uh that's what makes me quite a sad it's
a missed opportunity
well yeah and whether whether you think
it's aliens or not it's
it's a missed opportunity but you know
we weren't prepared and we will be
prepared for
the next ones and um as
so there's been a movement in astronomy
more towards what's called time domain
astronomy so kind of monitoring
the whole sky all the time at all
wavelengths that's kind of the goal and
so we expect to detect many more of
these in the future
even though these were the first two we
saw our potential to detect them is only
increasing with time and so there will
be more
opportunities and you know based on
these two we now can
actually sit and think about what we'll
do when the next one shows up
i also what it made me realize i know i
didn't
really think through this but it made me
realize if there is alien civilizations
out there
the thing we're most likely to see first
would be space junk
my stupid understanding of it the second
would be really dumb kind of
you could think of maybe like relay
nodes or something
objects that you need to have a whole
lot of
for particular purposes of like space
travel and so on
like uh speed limit signs or something i
don't know whatever we have on earth a
lot of
that's dumb it's not alien aliens in
themselves
it's like artifacts that are useful to
the engineering
in the systems that are engineered by
alien civilizations so like
it would we would see a lot of stuff
in terms of study in terms of looking
for alien life and trying to communicate
with it
maybe we should be looking not for like
smart creatures
or systems to communicate with maybe we
should be
looking for artifacts or even as dumb as
like space junk it just uh kind of
reframed my
perspective of like what are we looking
for as signs
is there there could be a lot of stuff
that doesn't have intelligence but gives
us really
strong signs that there's somewhere is
life or intelligent life
and uh yeah that made me kind of
i know it might be dumb to say but
reframe the kind of thing that we should
be looking for
yeah it's so the the benefit of looking
for intelligent life is that we perhaps
have a better chance of recognizing it
um yeah we couldn't necessarily
recognize what an alien stop sign look
like
um that's true and maybe you know the
the theorists are
the people who sort of model and try to
understand solar system objects are
are pretty good at coming up with models
for anything i mean maybe umua was a
stop sign
but we're clever enough that we could
come up with
some physical explanations for it and
then you know we all want to go with the
simplest possible
we all want to believe the sort of most
skeptical uh possible explanation and so
we missed it because we're too good at
coming up with alternate explanations
for things
and it's such an outlier such a rare
phenomenon that we can't
we can't study you know a hundred or a
thousand of these objects we have
we had just one and so the science
almost destroys
uh the possibility of something special
being there it's like a
uh johnny ive this designer of apple i
don't know if you know who that is
he's the lead designer he's the person
who designed the iphone and
all the major things and he talked about
he's brilliant
one of my favorite humans on earth and
one of the best designers in the history
of earth he talked about like when he
had this
origins of an idea like in his baby
stages he would not tell steve jobs
because steve would usually like trample
all over it he would say this is dumb
idea
and so i sometimes think of the
scientific community in that sense
because
the the weapon of the scientific method
is so strong
at its best that it sometimes crushes
the out of the box outlier
evidence you know we don't get a lot of
that evidence
because we don't have um we're not lucky
enough to have a lot of evidence so we
have to deal with just
special cases and special cases could
present an inkling of something much
bigger
but the scientific method user tramples
all over and it's hard to know what to
do
with that because the scientific method
works
but at the same time every once in a
while it's like a balance
you have to do 99 of the time you have
to do like scientific rigor
but every once in a while this is not
you saying me saying
smoke some weed and sit back and think
i wonder you know it's the joe rogan
thing it's entirely possible
that it's alien space junk
anyway yeah i think so i i completely
agree and i think that
most scientists do speculate about these
things it's just
at what point do you act on those things
um
so you're right that the scientific
method has inherent skepticism and for
the most part
that's a good thing because it means
that we're not just believing
crazy things all the time but
it's an interesting point that
requiring that high level of rigor
occasionally means that you will miss
something that is
truly interesting because you needed to
verify it
three times and it wasn't verifiable i
also think like when you communicate
with the general public
i think there's power in that one
percent speculation
of just demonstrating authenticity as a
human being as a curious human being
i think too often the i think this is
changing
but uh i saw i've been quite
disappointed my colleagues
throughout 2020 with the with with the
coronavirus
there's too much speaking from authority
as opposed to speaking from curiosity
there's some of the most incredible
science has been done in in 2020
especially on the virology biology side
and the kind of being talked down to by
scientists
is always really disappointing to me as
opposed to inspiring
like the things we there's a lot of
uncertainty about the coronavirus
but we know a lot of stuff and we speak
from
uh scientists from various disciplines
speak from data
in the face of that uncertainty and
we're curious we don't know what the
hell is going on we don't know if this
virus is going to evolve
evolve mutate we don't know if this
virus or the next one
might you know might destroy all human
civilization you can't speak with
certain
in fact i you know i was on a on a
survey paper about masks
something i don't talk much about
because i don't like politics
but we don't know if masks work but
there's a lot of evidence to show that
they work for this particular
the transmission of the virus is
fascinating actually the
the biomechanics of the way viruses
spread
is fascinating it if it wasn't
destructive
it would be beautiful and we don't know
but it's it's inspiring to to apply the
scientific mess that the
to the best of our ability but also to
show that you don't always know
everything
and to and perhaps not about the virus
as much but
other things speculate what if you know
what what if it's uh the worst case in
the best case
and um because that's ultimately what we
are descendants of apes that are just
curious about the world around us
yeah i uh i'll just add to that not on
the topic of
masks but on the topic of curiosity
that's
um i mean i think that's
astronomy and planetary sciences a field
are a little are are unique because
for better and for worse they don't
directly impact humanity um
so you know we're not studying virology
to
to prevent transmission of um
you know illness amongst humans we're
not
characterizing volcanoes on earth that
could destroy cities we
and it really is a more curious
and in my opinion playful scientific
field than many
um yeah so for better and worse we can
kind of afford
to pursue some of the speculation more
because
human lives are not in danger if we
speculate a little bit too freely
and get something wrong yeah definitely
in the space of ai i am worried that
we're sometimes too eager
speaking for myself to uh like flip
the switch to on just to see like what
happens uh maybe
sometimes we want to be a little bit
careful about that because uh
bad things might happen
you